don't hate your competitors respect your
competitors having competitors is a good
thing when I'm on a movie set I think
everybody is just as important as I am
rise and shine it's expresso time good
morning believe nation it seven my one
word is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have an amazing gift inside
you that I want to see exploded on to
the world
so grab your coffee and sip on today's
message respect your competitors over to
you Jack Ma who's your most dangerous
competitor is it Amazon or is it
ten-second well people always think
compare us with Emma's Evers a great
company I respect I've been seeing them
from a tiny to that big and I think they
will continue to grow but we are
different we Emerson is an e-commerce
company we are not ecommerce company we
enable other people to do ecommerce we
want to making sure everybody can be
Amazon so you saying $0.10 is the
greater tension is of course their
greater company and you know it's it's
not easy to be that size within only
such less than 20 years so innovative
and so creative are so different on
social technology and they're basting
certainly in dungeon and they are almost
everywhere in China but respect of
course we compete but compete does not
mean I have to hate them don't hate your
competitors respect your competitors
learn from him but you know pony and I
we've been doing the charity together
the Nature Conservancy and protected the
or but we compete each other but when we
compete each other we should respect
each other I respect him
I respect himself having competitors is
a good thing they force you to
your game they forced you to get better
to get stronger and they prevent you
from getting fat and slow and lazy and
lethargic competition is a great thing
the Yankees need the Red Sox coke needs
Pepsi NASA needs SpaceX we need our
competition nobody wants to run a race
against three-year-olds when you do
you're gonna win every time and it's not
gonna be a challenge for you you want to
grow you want to get better I looked at
my youtube channel and last year was in
a race to try to get two million
subscribers my goal for the end of the
year was to hit 1 million subscribers
and when I realized I was gonna get that
I was looking at my biggest competition
was Gary Vaynerchuk at the time and I
was excited to see who's gonna hit a
million first now he probably didn't
really care but for me I liked it I
liked that I liked the back-to-back I
liked seeing who was ahead I liked
having somebody pushing me to do more
and when he took a break in the summer
and he just handed to his team and his
channel tanked a little bit I was a
little sad because there was no
competition because I knew what I was
gonna I was gonna beat him to a million
and now it's excited again cuz he's
bringing up his game he's getting better
he's growing faster and now I have to up
my game to get even better and get get
higher and get faster and above I love
what Gary's doing I'm a huge fan of his
channel I'm not in YouTube or doing what
I do only to beat Gary Vaynerchuk that
is not my goal I'm making videos because
I love it and I love what he's doing for
the entrepreneur community and everybody
else who's making videos to help you
guys too
but having people who are close to you
or having people who are ahead of you
they push you to be stronger and to do
more and to go just that little bit
extra the other day I had a subscriber
write in to me to say hey Evan I love
your content I haven't been on your
channel for a while and it's all your
fault because you introduced me to Tom
bill you from impact theory and I've
been going down a rabbit hole just
consuming all of his content I tweeted
that out to Tom because if I'm gonna
lose subscriber I'm glad it's going to
him and now tom is still behind on the
growth for his channel compared to ours
but he's catching up and and I love it
like I want Tom to get better I want
time to get better because it'll push me
to do more and it's a great win for the
entre unity for all of you guys he has
great content and so you need to respect
your competitors I think it's important
I think if you understand that yes you
want to beat them
but that they are making you be a better
version of you it really really helps
drive progress so if you look at this
business trying to dance salsa we're the
biggest school in Canada we're probably
bigger than all the other schools in the
country combined at least in this area
for sure combined and so I don't look at
our competitors as competitors right I
don't look at what the other salsa
schools are doing in the area and saying
look what they're doing because we're
just so much further ahead of them so we
need to have somebody pushing us so I
look at who we compete against really is
gonna be the movie theater is gonna be
the bars is gonna be the pit bull
concert it's the entertainment dollar
and so I look at what those guys are
doing say I'm competing with Starbucks
I'm competing with famous players I'm
competing with the movie theaters that's
who I'm competing with oh it's this
competition now that's driving for us to
get better again competition is not the
reason why we do this we teach salsa
because we love it because we try to
create that sense of community here
because people come in without friends
and with low self-esteem when they come
out with an entire new group of friends
with confidence huge smiles and you see
that have a ripple effect out to the
entire life that's why we do it but the
competition helps you just sharpen that
knife a little bit more usually that
extra push extra oomph so that you can
be the best version of yourself possible
now I've got some really special bonus
clips for you but before getting to that
my question of the day is who is a
competitor that you respect the most and
have learned the most from leave it down
in the comments below I'm really curious
to find out thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever you're one where it is much
love enjoy the bonus clips and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot event spresso
they spray so give me go
but then I was in the die hard office
one day and there's a sign on the on the
on the wall that I adhere to family now
that said be careful of the toes you
step on today for they could be
connected to the ass you'll have to kiss
tomorrow and believe me they're been pas
and other people like when I'm on a
movie set I think everybody is just as
important as I am or I treat them that
way so I know pas names I talked to him
I speak to him every day I speak to the
gaffer's I speak to the grips I speak to
all these people and over the years I've
gotten jobs and the producer will show
up and he'll be like you you don't
remember me but I was a PA on our song
song son you were so nice to me that you
know and I was doing this movie I
couldn't help but think you know that
you would be the perfect and that [ __ ]
works out you know or they become
writers or they become directors you
know but it's a collaborative effort I
mean we're we're almost the least
important element of any film because if
[ __ ] ain't putting the lights
up right or the soundman mic is jacked
up it'll mean about what you're doing
cuz nobody can see you are here you know
so they can fix that in the mix you know
but everything else has got to work
we have learnt a lot from every one of
our competitors there is no doubt at all
and we respect them one of the articles
of faith that emphasis is never ever
underestimate your competitors always
respect them learn what you can from
them and that's the way you can beat
them I think to respect your opposition
your teammates is really important I can
understand everyone is out here to win
not everyone can be with us but you can
definitely win everyone's hearts you can
you can win some games we can lose some
lives
in my career I haven't won of all the
games but something which sport teaches
you is when there is failure when you're
faced with challenges sport teaches you
to get back on your feet again and
compete harder in the right spirit and
that's what my message to you would be
complete heart but playing the right
spirit and respect your sport of our
[Music]
evolving you ever if you had to think of
one word that's most important to you or
that sums you up or that would be like a
little beacon they believe nation if you
want to know what the most important one
word is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details